en este vídeo lo que quiero hacer es
enfocarme en presentar algunos
ejercicios que podrían venir en algún
examen porque bueno supongo que verás
algunos similar en algún examen alguna
vez en tu vida entonces lo que voy a
hacer es primero ponerlos en la pantalla
porque no lo he hecho lo voy a copiar y
pegar de la página ahí esta copiar y
copiar y pegar perfecto ok
ahí está se nos pregunta la ecuación 3
que multiplica a 2 x 4 igual a menos 18
es equivalente a 6 x 12 igual a menos 18
bueno vamos a distribuir este 3 sobre
esto entonces 3 x 2 x es igual a 6 x y 3
x menos 4 es igual a menos 12 igual a 18
así que en efecto son equivalentes si
destruir si distribuimos este 3 sobre
eso 2 x 4 obtenemos 6 x menos 12 la
respuesta es sí y ésta no no cuenta
ahora son equivalentes por la propiedad
asociativa no esa no es por la
conmutativa tampoco pero por la la
opción por la distribución de la
multiplicación sobre la suma esa es la
respuesta así que la encontramos
entonces porque estamos viendo que el 3
se distribuye sobre el 2x menos cuatro
cierto 3 se distribuye sobre 2 x menos 4
y nos da 6 x menos 12 ahora por qué se
le llama distribución de multiplicación
sobre la suma x
como puedes ver el 3 está multiplicando
a 2x más menos 4 cierto pero bueno en
fin vamos con el siguiente el siguiente
ejercicio el número 2 que nos dice aquí
dice raíz de 16 más la raíz cúbica de 8
que es igual esto raíz de 16 a cuál es
la raíz cuadrada de 16 es la raíz
principal a la que me refiero no es más
menos 4 sino sólo el 4 positivo entonces
tenemos 4 tengo 4 más ahora que el
número x el mismo 3 veces nos da 8 2 al
cubo es igual a 8 cierto 2 al cubo es
igual a 8 es lo mismo que la raíz cúbica
de 8 es igual a 2 o puedes ver esto como
8 a la potencia un tercio entonces
cuatro más dos es igual a seis es la
opción verde de la página que estoy
viendo ahora vamos con el problema 3 ya
terminamos el problema 3
quieren saber bueno mejor voy a copiar y
pegar no lo voy a escribir todo copio y
pego más fácil la vida entonces
ahí están copio y
y lo pegó aquí okay perfecto dice qué
expresión es equivalente a equis a la
sexta x x al cuadrado x a la sexta x x
al cuadrado tienen tienen la misma base
entonces vamos a sumar los exponentes
simplemente tenemos 6 más 2 es igual a 8
entonces x a la octava potencia no está
en las opciones entonces veamos cuál de
estas opciones es igual a equis a la
octava potencia entonces ok sumamos los
exponentes 43 es igual a 7 y aquí cinco
másters es igual a 8 cierto así que la
respuesta es la opción b
ok perfecto ahora vamos con el siguiente
problema el número 4 el número 4 que
está bastante interesante
ok entonces lo copió y lo pego copio y
pego ahí está el problema número 4 que
número no tiene recíproco de estas
opciones
aquí tenemos menos 1 su recíproco es 1
sobre menos 1 lo cual es igual a menos 1
la opción b hay algo sospechoso su
recíproco es 1 sobre 0 pero eso no es
posible en este momento ha explotado el
universo porque no podemos dividir entre
0 así que la opción b es la correcta
ahora el pse si tiene recíproco su
recíproco
mil esto es igual a 1000
y ahora la opción de el recíproco de 13
es un tercio y bueno ya terminamos con
el ejercicio 4 ahora vamos con el
siguiente ejercicio
ok en este hay mucha terminología tal
vez pero creo que es bueno de todos
modos no no pasa nada quieren saber de
hecho voy a copiar y pegar también aquí
y también el siguiente ejercicio
entonces 2 en 1 ok voy a ponerlo sobre
este ahí está ok quieren saber cuál es
el inverso multiplicativo de un medio
esencialmente se me pide que que puedo
multiplicar por un medio tal que obtenga
como resultado 1 o cuál es el inverso de
un medio el inverso de un medio de hecho
lo voy a escribir así el inverso de un
medio es 1 sobre un medio esto es lo
mismo que 1 por 2 sobre 1 es igual a 2
otra manera de pensar en esto sería 2
por un medio es igual a 1 por lo tanto
el inverso multiplicativo de un medio es
simplemente 2 cierto la opción es la de
ahora número 6 cuál es la solución para
esta ecuación
tal vez los valores absolutos te
resulten terroríficos pero no veamos
aquí dice si él
absoluto de 2 x 3 es igual a 5 entonces
eso que nos dice dice que 2 x menos 3 es
igual a 5 por un lado como valor
absoluto pero 2 x menos 3 que a que más
puede ser igual veamos a ok qué pasa si
esto si esto es igual a menos 5 si 2 x
menos 3 es igual a menos 5 el valor
absoluto de menos 5 también es igual a 5
entonces ok entonces entonces 2 x menos
3 es igual a menos 5 también es una
opción así que en este caso estás aquí
tomando el valor absoluto de lo que es 5
o menos 5 y el valor absoluto de 5 o de
menos 5 cualquiera de los dos es igual a
5 así que tenemos aquí si sumamos 3 a
ambos lados obtenemos 2x es igual a 8 y
x es igual a 4 ahora el siguiente
sumamos 3 entonces 2x es igual a menos
53 es igual a menos 2x
a menos dos sobre dos es igual a menos
uno menos uno así que la respuesta
tenemos x igual a 4 x igual a menos 1
eso es igual a c la opción se es la la
respuesta correcta para este ejercicio
número 6 ahora vamos con el siguiente
como ves hemos hemos avanzado bastante
rápido
ok entonces voy a borrar todo esto lo
borro y nueva pantalla negra ahí está ok
entonces lo escribo el 7 dice cuál es el
conjunto solución para la desigualdad
5 - el valor absoluto de x 4 menor o
igual a menos 3 ahora tal vez me hace
esto y digas wow qué onda con esto pero
vamos a simplificarlo o intentemos
simplificarlo para verás que no no están
tan horroroso entonces lo que vamos a
hacer es tratar de dejar el valor
absoluto de un lado aquí vamos a quitar
este 5 y cómo lo hacemos restando lo
cierto restando lo de ambos lados de la
ecuación para que se mantenga
igualdad entonces hacemos eso vamos a
restar del lado izquierdo resto el 5
entonces pongo aquí menos 5 + 5 y acá
también menos 5 ahora aquí aquí esto es
un más es un más así que del lado
izquierdo nos va a quedar solamente
menos el valor absoluto de x más 4 menor
o igual a esto es igual a menos 8 menos
8 menos 8 y otra cosa importante muy
importante de hecho tenemos una
desigualdad no una igualdad entonces si
tuviéramos una igualdad simplemente
multiplicamos ambos lados o dividimos
entre menos uno para deshacernos de ese
menos uno o el signo menos junto al
valor absoluto cierto pero tenemos una
desigualdad entonces
eso afecta porque al multiplicar ambos
lados por menos uno va a cambiar el
signo de desigualdad así que hagamos
esto menos uno que multiplica menos el
valor absoluto de x + 4 se cambia el
signo a mayor o igual y nos queda menos
8 y también vamos a multiplicar ese
menos 8 x menos 1 ahora menos 1 y este
menos 1 se cancela nos queda el valor
absoluto de x + 4 es mayor o igual que
menos 8 x menos 1 es igual a 8 entonces
aquí ya tenemos la misma forma que en el
ejercicio pasado cierto vamos a usar la
misma lógica tenemos que la magnitud de
x 4 es mayor o igual que 8 entonces
magnitud lo que voy a hacer es dibujar
una recta numérica para para que sea más
sencillo visualizar esto tenemos aquí
esta recta numérica y entonces el valor
absoluto de x más 4 estamos aquí viendo
la distancia que hay del cero
a lo que sea eso cierto entonces aquí
tenemos 0 y aquí tenemos el 8 positivo
acá está el 8 negativo entonces la
distancia de esto será mayor o igual que
8 veamos a que es igual eso entonces
tenemos aquí la recta numérica ya con el
8 y menos 8 y tenemos este número en la
distancia del 0 a ese número que está
dentro del valor absoluto debe ser mayor
o igual que 8 entonces en efecto es
mayor que 8 de eso no hay menor duda
pero ahora es es la magnitud que hay
desde aunque es mayor o igual que 8
entonces aquí estos números también van
a incluirse y porque tiene sentido eso
bueno pues tomemos algún ejemplo que te
parece el número 9 menos nueve perdón
menos nueve el valor absoluto de menos
nueve que es igual esto esto es mayor
que 89 es mayor que 8 entonces cualquier
número mayor o igual que 8 cumple y
también
menor que o bueno en menor que menos 8
cierto entonces ok
aquí tenemos entonces que la magnitud x
+ 4 es mayor o igual que 8 por un lado
serían estos en la magnitud en esta
dirección y por otro lado tendríamos x 4
menor o igual que 8 son los números que
van en en esta en esta dirección la
magnitud hacia la izquierda
así que hay que resolver esto
simplemente observa o bueno visualiza el
valor absoluto como como una magnitud la
distancia que hay del 0 a este número
entonces si lo pones en una recta
numérica se puede ver fácil que estos
números que están dentro del valor
absoluto x 4 deben cumplir ser mayor o
igual que 8 o menor o igual que 8 así
que resolvamos esto aquí tenemos x + 4
mayor o igual que ochos restamos 4 de
ambos lados de la ecuación y tenemos x
es mayor o igual que 4 simplemente reste
4 ahora acá también voy a restar
de ambos lados y obtenemos x es menor o
igual que menos 12 entonces estas son
las respuestas x mayor o igual que 4 o x
menor o igual que 12 y ahí está la
respuesta es la de los tenemos bien
bueno nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo